the layla and alex love story so series  of unfortunate events i had a head on  dui right after that i put all the money  from selling my five gyms into a new  company and then the partner that i had  in that new company ended up taking the  money i had 23 000 left to my name i  owed the salesman who had made the  hundred thousand dollars in sales twenty  two thousand dollars in commissions it  was at that moment where i said i have a  hundred thousand dollar limit on this  credit card i'm at her parents house  sleeping in their room i was like okay  this could go horribly wrong i'm gonna  be going into debt at 3 300 a day so  when i it was like i think i'm a sinking  ship right now like nothing else has  worked and so like i respect you if you  want to dip out and so that was when she  said she would she would stay with me  and so she was willing to hang with me  which was going to be hard and she was  like think about how epic this story is  going to be like when we make it